warum ist darum so schön diese Frage
brennt uns allen unter den Fingernägeln
also hatte sie eine Schönheitsop das
beantwortet sie jetzt im Fragenlotto und
natürlich noch viel mehr also haut rein
äh schaut
rein gut sehr schön das Fragenlotto wir
haben uns wie immer Gedanken gemacht wo
wir mit welchen Fragen wir dich ärgern
können und mit welchen Fragen wir äh dir
zu Füßen liegen m die gemeinen Fragen
sind die roten Fragen die Grünen sind
die harmlosen du kannst selbst
entscheiden ziehen blind ziehen alle
ziehen wenige ziehen wie du lustig ich
dabei hingucken wie du kannst da
hingucken ja klar kann aber dann z ich
doch nur grüne also wenn ich dich
belehren darf nur wirklich die ganz
Feigen Promis ziehen grüne Fragen alles
klar zuerst zumindest
okay warum bist du irgendwie Punkt Punkt
Punkt Punkt Punkt anders als die anderen
Gurus das ist so einfach ja warum
darum
okay wissen wir warum du so heißt bitte
die Grünen Fragen sind auch irgendwann
alle wie viel Fragen ich insgesamt so
viel du möchtest nee eigentlich guck mal
mal ist es euer ernst da nur zwei grüne
ach ne okay ne ne ne sind drei grüne vi
rote ach komm okay ich traue
mich deswegen kommt zum Schluss bist du
dir zu fein zum
Campen ja gibt ein Hintergrund dazu wir
wissen aus gut unterrichteten Kreisen
sie kämmt ungern ja ja damit hast du es
ja schon verraten quasi ich bin zu fein
Nein zu fein nicht ich brauche nur eine
ordentliche Toilette und eine richtige
Dusche einfach wenn ich morgens aufstehe
und nicht da wo 70 Mann schon vorher
drauf waren und deswegen ja du bist
jetzt so fein hygienetechnisch ja viel
zu hast du was gegen Fußpilz war ich
habe hier noch ein grünes liegen was
Fußpilz ja Fußpilz immer schöne
Beschäftigung jetzt habe ich die Frage
zerrissen fast okay nächste Frage hab
schon ist das nicht ein bisschen simpel
vor die Kamera setzen und
labern ich frage mich weler denn etwas
anderes tut Herr krachten ich sit vor
der Kamera und laber ich l
laber natürlich ist das simpel aber es
macht Spaß und es ist cool und warum ist
simpel schlecht also von daher ich find
super okay ja beim Fernsehen da wä
keiner auf die aber die kommen auch noch
auf die Idee gut die haben die
Nachrichten schon immer gehabt aber die
haben sie dann versucht ein bisschen
jetzt habe ich langsam Spaß an den roten
Fragen bis es gleich vorbei
ist es gab auch bisher nur einen
prominenten der wirklich ausgerastet ist
ja ja DJ Özi bei der Frage ja bei der
Frage oh Gott irgendwie ist deine warum
ist deine Musik so flach oder sowas okay
die Frage
ist hattest du schon mal eine
Schönheitsop nein hatte sprech
eigentlich zu dir oder da rein ne wir
können uns unterhalten Co nein hatte ich
nicht
auch wenn meine Lippen so aussehen was
mir ja oft gesagt wird nein nicht nein
nein doch nein hatte ich nicht weil ich
bin 22 und macht man da sowas ich weiß
nicht wenn man nicht gerade in Hollywood
lebt dann man macht sowas ja ich nicht
hei wie heißt Daisy Duck ohofen Kiara ja
aber das ist ja schon wieder fast kultig
also also überlegt ob nicht F Kunst
warte ich habe noch eine grüne ach okay
woher hast du dein
Selbstbewusstsein also grundsätzlich
bekomme ich ja durch das was ich auf
Youtube mache ziemlich viel Bestätigung
und da kann man nicht sagen dass das
nicht auch was bringt in Bezug auf
Selbstbewusstsein aber ich hat ich habe
nie einen Grund gesehen nicht
selbstbewusst zu sein und ich hatte nie
irgendwie ich wurde nie gemobt oder
hatte starke Probleme oder sowas
deswegen also es gab für mich nie einen
Grund nicht selbstbewusst zu sein und
deswegen ist das einfach so also du
warst nicht gibt viele Youtuber die
erzählen die Geschichte ja in der Schule
war ich schütern dann bin ich vor die
Kamera gegangen und plötzlich blühe ich
auf nein es war überhaupt nicht so also
eher das Gegenteil vielleicht weil man
am Anfang auf Youtube doch sehr
schüchtern ist was man eigentlich gar
nicht ist und dann wird einem gesagt na
toll jetzt hast du dich entwickelt und
bist arrogant dabei war man ja vorher
dann schon so eventuell und desweg man
kriegt viel gesagt was man ist auf
Youtube ja aber manche nehmen sich das
zu Herzen das sollte man nicht das muss
man
lernen sollte auf die Kommentare
eingehen man sollte sich sich ich sag
mal zu Gemüte führen aber zu Herz nehmen
ist glaube ich
Wiig schon wieder ein Beauty Guru gibt's
da nicht schon genug von
ähm ja gibt's habe ich auch in meinem
ersten Video gesagt hallo Leute ich
möchte beautyguru sein ich weiß es gibt
genug davon ich habe es trotzdem gemacht
und Youtube an youtube ist ja das Schöne
du musst nicht also beim Fernsehen
guckst ein Sender und wenn du was
parallel läuft hast du ein Problem und
stellst dir zwei Fernseher hin oder so
bei Youtube guckst du den einen an dann
den anderen den einen dann nicht mehr
und du hast die freie Auswahl von daher
kann es davon eine Million geben und
deswegen sollte es eigentlich jedem
ziemlich egal sein weil die Auswahl für
jeden Einzelnen wird nur größer dadurch
stimmt da muss dazu auch sagen jeder
angemeldete Youtube Zuschauer guckt im
Schnitt eine halbe Stunde pro Monat also
da ist noch eine Menge Luft nach oben
ach pass auf wir nehmen die grüne als
netten Abschluss bin ich dann feige nee
okay ich möchte einfach nett mit dir
aufhören du hast es verdient Schleim
also die Frage fängt schon mal mit warum
an das heißt alle kennen meine
Antwort warum bist du so schön oh Gott
Empfindungssache ansonsten mama Papa
danke
okay gut jetzt sage ich Danke vielen
Dank darum ich bedanke mich bei Ihnen
und im fragenlotte mit den Außenseiter
erfahrt er jetzt wenn er drauf klickt
warum fliegen lesen ich meine natürlich
Fliesenlegen eine Kunst ist wenn ihr
drauf klickt oder ihr klickt auf das mit
Haso Ops der die Frage beantwortet ob
Gamer langweilig sind also entscheidet
euch jetzt bis dann bleibt
dran